[Music]
hi
my name is michael chow and thanks for
watching this r studio conf talk
i'll be going through suba which is a
port of d plier to python
since you're watching our studio conf
i'm guessing that you're on board with r
and d plier for data analysis and i've
got to say i love r
but i also love python and depending on
the project or task
i've often found myself having to switch
between r and python
or sort of juggle both at the same time
and i'm guessing this isn't a super
unusual experience since python's just
incredibly
popular if you look at stack overflow
posts the
sort of predominant tool in python for
data analysis pandas
accounts for about three percent of
posts a month
there's just an incredible amount and so
a lot of my interactions have been with
people
who use pandas for data analysis but as
time has gone on i found myself reaching
more and more for deep liar
and i've really thought a lot about that
and tried to figure out what's going on
there
and to kind of like set the stage i
thought i'd just use a dumb analogy
that pandas is a lot maybe like a
double-decker bus
so this is in hong kong and this thing's
really built for carrying capacity
if you have to ship like 80 humans
somewhere this is your tool
right you stack them on top of each
other you're golden
the challenge is that it's kind of
cumbersome right it can't go everywhere
it's probably scary to back up and in
contrast
in hong kong there's another vehicle the
minibus
or suba that's the opposite approach
so tiny capacity holds like 16 people
and it's just a terror on wheels so the
bbc
describes it as hong kong's wildest ride
and these things are just
fast they can go anywhere and they can
sort of
get you they're super flexible so
i kind of think that that really reminds
me of d plier
that d pliers incredible for exploratory
analysis
it can just get you to where you want to
go
quickly pandas is great at computation
but can be a little bit cumbersome sort
of on the fly
so subba aims to be small but mighty
by leveraging d plier like syntax in
python
but doing computation behind the scenes
in pandas
or sql and i've tried to live code with
suba just to sort of battle test it
and make sure it's ready for the big
time
um i think a big question is what d
plier
is really doing that's so useful
and to really understand we have to go
back to hadley's 2014 talk where he
introduced dplyr
and he mentions that analysts sort of
have two bottlenecks
a cognitive bottleneck and a
computational bottleneck
the computational ones the most we think
of the one we think of most often
which is as the data becomes bigger it
takes longer to run the code
but intriguingly hadley mentions he
thinks a lot about the cognitive
bottleneck
which is how should we think about the
data and describe what we want to do
to the data or code and dplyr aims at
this cognitive bottleneck
to help people sort of focus their
thoughts and to give people strategies
for
data analysis it does this by
kind of slimming down taking this big
space and slimming down the options
that people have so there are five
simple verbs
and all of these critically can combine
with an operator group by
all of these take a data frame and
return a data frame
and he mentions that overall it's a very
constrained design
especially compared to his previous tool
plyar
so suba aims to sort of let people
capture those d plier-like thoughts
and keep them while writing d-player
syntax
in python and then um doing the
computation
in pandas so the gist is suba lets you
transfer your thoughts
from r to python
all right so i'm going to try to show
three motivating cases where
it can be tricky to transfer d player
thoughts to pandas
three roadblocks that people hit and i
know it's tempting to see
dplyr and pandas is pretty similar so in
this example
they're doing roughly the same thing and
they're using basically the same code
so it's a group summarize um we're
calculating the average of a column
and we're renaming the result average hp
and we get roughly the same output
but it's also worth noting if you take
to somewhere like twitter
or look around you'll see some pretty
scathing reviews
so d pliers forever ruined pandas for me
or chelsea notes every picture
shows pandas and chaos um and i think
it's worth noting these people i think
they like
pandas so this isn't a straight critique
of pandas but it can be really
frustrating
when you try to go from one tool and the
way it structures thinking
to another and so i would say
these three cases try to bring that to
the surface what's going on
the first row block is select so select
is really a very basic action
you can choose columns you can drop
columns you might match
certain columns or rename a column and
the trick is that
pandas uses different names for all
these actions so there are four
different methods
for one for each action the other thing
is that
sometimes they have kind of funky
arguments you need to pass
so you might have to say axis equals one
to say oh i want to do this to the
columns
or you might have to say columns equals
those are kind of different ways of
saying the same
thing the last is that sometimes you
have to use sort of intense programming
constructs like a lambda function
if you want to do things like match on a
string
in contrast dplyr uses the same verb for
all these actions
select and it's really easy to to
change between what you're doing to go
from keeping a column to dropping a
column
or even to combine these actions
together
and so this is a case i think of where
sort of changing what you do
requires changing gears right and
shifting between
these different functions and methods in
pandas
the second example is i would say group
by
and this is really i would say grouping
is really a critical activity in data
analysis and d
plier and the pandas docs describe some
translations
from our to pandas and it looks pretty
straightforward at least for these cases
but actually i would say group by
and d player and pandas use radically
different
underlying grammars so in this example
on the left i'm showing a filter
in pandas or a mutate um
and note there are two ways of doing it
so or multiple ways
i should say um so you can use query
that's the top left
or eval on the top right or
an alternative way to filter on the
bottom left is these blocks
or to mutate a sign on the bottom right
critically we can ask what happens when
we try to group by
before these operations and the answer
is that
none of them work and the trick is
a group data in pandas a group a data
frame group by
actually doesn't have even any of these
methods on it to perform
these operations except in one case
where
the operation just sort of fails and
this is probably really surprising i
think for deep plier users
the trick ends up being you have to
shift the group by from
outside of the verb to inside it
so you basically have to move group by
into your
column operations and again this isn't
necessarily bad
and and it means pandas can still do the
same computations as d
plier it's just i think surprising for d
power users
and for me challenging to do when i'm
trying to analyze data
quickly the third row block i'd say is
sql
so um dplyr users
if you're like me uh in working in
industry i
lean on d plier and db player being able
to generate sql
heavily so you can just swap out your
data source to sql
and dplyr will generate a sql query for
you
in contrast if you're using pandas you
just need to switch to
writing sql and that's what i see happen
quite a bit in industry is
once it hits the database people just
switch and start coding sql
so your computation changes and how you
code
ends up changing as a result so to recap
dplyr is really powerful it uses one
verb
select for all the cases for grabbing
columns
for group by you have this sort of
really nice
expressive syntax where you can modify
the full table action
so you can have a grouped mutate or
grouped filter or group summarize
in contrast pandas is computationally
powerful
and it's packed with options but that
means that you might have to do a little
bit more work up front
during the analysis and this makes it
great for engineering
but maybe a big challenge i think for
exploratory data analysis
or quick analyses all right so we looked
at some core challenges in
translating dplyr thoughts about data
analysis to pandas
now i want to switch gears and look how
huba can help you
basically preserve those thoughts and
code them in python
and it aims to do this as sort of
faithfully to d plier as possible
so i'm going to show you an example of
going from d player code to suba
um i apologize uh i know i start with
these parentheses
and put the pipe at the beginning of the
line and some people hate that
um sorry my bad but um
so let's go ahead and just start the
switch so
first we'll change our imports so rather
than using library we'll do our python
imports
then we'll change the pipe to be greater
than greater than
next we'll put an underscore dot in
front of the variable names
and this sort of has to happen in order
for it to be python syntax
and then the last thing is a little bit
tricky
we're going to take this mean function
call and we're going to change it to
a method so it's more similar to how
pandas expresses
operations all right and so
in a sense with these few simple changes
we've gone from d plier and r to
suba in python
so and looking side by side hopefully my
goal is that you can kind of like squint
your eyes and they just look like the
same
code right and you can just figure out
how to swap between them
so now i want to go through the three
examples that i showed before
and just give you a sense for what they
look like in suba
so the first row block was select and
now looking back at this example
with suba on the left um it should be
basically the same thing now you just
have underscore dot
before the variable names um
it's worth 32 the very bottom one where
you select certain columns
it's really easy to do and it matches up
sort of with the pandas code
so pandas you can do this dot str dot
ends with and it will return true
whenever a column
matches that and suba just lines up
with that way of doing things so
corresponds to the pandas way
the second example is group by
um so we showed a few different ways of
doing filter and mutate
so the filter and mutate now for pandas
are on the right
and let's show how suba does it so
here's the subafilter mutate on the left
notice that they're eerily similar
hopefully to deep plier
and we can just tuck in the group by
above the filter mutate to make it a
grouped filter
or group mutate so it's meant to be easy
to just swap in
and out the last example was sql
so i think this is kind of the biggest
most useful part of suba
is you can swap out your data source
from being a pandas data frame
to a sql alchemy essentially a sql
alchemy connection
and suba will generate the sql query or
run the query and return a table of data
just like dplyer and right now it's
mostly
um postgres and redshift that i've
worked on supporting
but it can be extended to more back ends
so there's early support for mysql
and sqlite and i'm hoping to to build
those out
further i think one of the incredible
things is that you get gg plot for free
and that's not by any of my work but by
um
the work of a person named hassan um who
built a package called plot9
which is a port of an incredibly
faithful port of gg plot
so um ideally you can just
do the full data transformation data
visualization
right and you can carry over your
hard-earned skills from
r to python so just to recap
suba tries to use a very similar syntax
to d plier
there are some cases where it needed to
be tweaked a little bit
to be pythonic or to just be python
syntax
and incredibly it aims to bring you
sql and ggplot and i found that these
things
really helped me get back up to speed
and data analysis
and have been fun to just to carry into
python and to discuss
with people all right so we talked about
three roadblocks you might face
when translating d plier code and
thoughts to pandas
and how supa lets you sort of roll past
those by essentially
copying and pasting dplyr into python
now i want to zoom out a little bit and
ask why is subawarth in the long term
why should you try out or adopt suba
the first thing i want to harken back to
is hadley's point in 2014 about
cognition and computation
that d plier as a cognitive tool
has um if you've used it over the long
term probably really helped you build
skills
to ask important questions of your data
and those skills aren't even
maybe that related to programming so why
not just bring those skills with you
into python the next point is
suba uses d pliers architecture and this
lets it
very flexibly add new back ends so
whether you run against sql or pandas
suba can support it and i'm hoping to
extend support to
python specific tools in the future like
desk
and tools like spark as well as fleshing
out mysql support
the next thing is that supa runs just an
enormous glut
of continuous integration tests so
it's incredibly thoroughly tested i
would say it's like paranoid about
ensuring that you get the same result
back whether you're running on sql or
pandas
and every time i push code it runs
thousands of tests
the last thing is um
developer docs so i've tried to leave a
nice trail of breadcrumbs
so if you're curious about the internal
workings of suba or looking to
patch or extend it there are just
enormous resources to do that i'd
suggest the programming guide in the
superdox which goes through
all of sue's parts or i have
something called architectural decision
records in github
that document key decisions i made why
they were made
and contained sketches of those
decisions
the last thing is if you're interested
in learning suba
there are some nice alleys you can go
down so the first thing i'd recommend
is dave robinson's tidy tuesday
screencasts
these are actually an r so maybe not as
related but they were an incredible
resource
when developing suba and actually a big
motivation to work
on it i think being able to see a person
move quickly through data analyses in a
holistic setting
is really important and tidy tuesday is
a project that releases new data every
week
lets you sort of see things in action
the other thing is there is an
interactive tutorial for suba
on learn.suba.org so if you're curious
to just
get started even if you've never coded
before the tutorials made
to make it easy to get started it's
something i've tested on my family and
friends
and i'm really excited for the
opportunity for suba to make it really
easy for learners
to take their first steps into coding
and data analysis
um the last thing is that i've tried to
put up
live analyses on youtube of analyzing
data for an hour
whether it's translating dave's analyses
from r
into suba python or doing tidy tuesday
data
analyses for an hour so i highly
recommend
watching those if you want to see suban
action and then
trying tsuba out on tidy tuesday just
take it for a spin and see
how what it looks like and how it
compares say to using
r or another python tool so just to
recap
you can find suba on github at mhl
suba you can pip install it
um i can't highly recommend tidy tuesday
enough
um it'll let you get a feel for
what data analysis wisuba looks like
and there's learn.suba.org if you've
never coded
i've tried to design this for you and
i'd love to see
people take their first steps into data
analysis through this course
so thanks to everybody who helped
contribute to suba
thanks to our studio for putting this
together and thanks to the army of
people who gave feedback on this talk
and made it much much better than its
first version
so thanks for watching i hope you'll try
suba out
and if you have any questions please
feel free to reach out to me
on github or on twitter at chow the dog
thanks
[Music]
you